hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde ihr seht schon wieder ist sie
ziemlich alleine sondern ich weiß ehrt
mich aber wir machen heute mal wieder
einen nicht lachen challenge das kann's
ja immer richtig gut von würde ich sagen
starten wir direkt ich find die retter
[Musik]
konnten sich gehabt habe
dann als seine nicht lachen challenge
wir sind ein bisschen gesagt darauf weil
die challenges nicht zu lachen weil wir
dieser überschrift wenn ich in der
klasse geburtstagskinder tor und jap
kostet 700 euro
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
kuckuck kuckuck bewusst nicht
[Gelächter]
vor allem albaner mit catalana sind
richtig patriotisch auf instagram was
ist das patriot sprachenlernen
badewassers woher kommen patrioten
[Gelächter]
aus welchem land kommen patrioten
deutschland ist das bka von den ach das
ist der airport menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend sogar drei tage sagt
ja
[Musik]
während schwarz ich muss sie weg in die
schule einen kindergarten sind also
viele kommen dann doch noch
das fällt ja selten ins meer
mein leben ist herrlich ich genieße
jeden tag weil gegen bin rein und ich er
ist nochmal sachsen vom michael vom
genau von sachsen-anhalt sonne genau der
ist das ja gucken wir deine staub gegen
der alter übels peinlich als ich mich
gar nicht verstaubt drauf ist oder nicht
lukas was denn so wirst du niemals eine
freundin finden nach mädel sachen boni
dort staub auf dem mikrofon
es nicht verstanden
überall so heiße mädels im film dann
will der sei am ende so seine frau
besteht also im cockpit
[Musik]
du willst du bist das wir sind beide
single ja aber ich mache es ist das
richtige
das könnte doch du sein ich bin von
einer schülerin zu finanzieren schüler
geworden aber ich mache das richtige
laufen und sollte auch darüber
warum
patriot
warum patriot da unten da scheinbar
patriot irgendwann muss man einfach mal
so einen deutschkurs mit ihr mache mit
keine sonder ich hab meine mio
[Musik]
das bin ich in der badewanne zu ganz
allein im badezimmer und raps damit vor
dich hin oder
[Musik]
deswegen war das was du gerade vor der
aufnahme gesunken
1000 vielleicht brauchen wir nicht nur
deutsch sondern auch um eine frage wie
heißt eigentlich stets instrument bei
hochzeiten das muss wie heißt das denn
nicht die angel oder sohn weiß was mit
ria mehr dass da das was du jetzt gerade
hier eingeblendet die sander und nein es
ist keine triangel
[Musik]
das sind so richtige ahlmann wird was du
jemals in der schule spaß ja ja ich war
nie hatte
nicht weil unsere toiletten auf unserer
gymnasium richtig ekelhaft aber eure
jungs hätten wir einen anderen verstopft
und so unsere nicht ja wenn alle meine
freunde waren ja ich war richtige heim
ist jetzt ja ist ja ok aber
[Musik]
kleine rohde hast du denn wenn die e
mails wenn er mit laura schluss machen
würdest du mit ihm zusammen kommen
der bot mal gucken ob ich das genauso
kann wie die rock eine chance henry ist
so witzig dass ich muss er drei tage
habe und wie fischen wollen
das waren jetzt fünf sekunden sie sind
einfach weg die kommune wieder und
montana blackminton black dahlia 7 von
deiner black mit dabei hat doch noch
keine tattoos und montana
er trat 1999 zurück und überließ
wladimir putin die macht der wirtschaft
[Musik]
norbert herr zimmer bock russischer
präsident zu sein ja klar
was wärst was zu machen wir das dicke
villa kaufen
ich meine sie als präsidentin behandlung
sobald politische handlung für das land
den hübschesten russen mehr klären
für das land alkohol was alkohol am
steuer
russland verkehrsunfall quote gesagt
vier milliarden prozent sowie garde
hätten wohl nirgendwo jungen von einem
transporter im seniorenheim an der
stelle würden sei noch nicht das heutige
video zu beenden wenn euch diese nicht
lachen ständig gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
da wir beide können das leider nicht so
gut bitte verzeiht uns samaras canalis
in der beschreibung verlinkt bei ihr sie
macht auch videos ab und zu
du hast die letzten drei wörter ich bin
nicht allzu aus deutschland
[Musik]